Es
muchas gracias en jesus lo bendiga
vino a mí me dijo mamá llamé
a la policía y pídale a la policía que
tráenos comida porque no
no habia nada bien mama yo podria hacer eso
era miguel de deus pero la policia no
responde esa llamada y la policía lo hace
otras cosas y en realidad no
crei que venia la policia
hola mamá hola
Y allá
Es O
miguel
Y allá
[Música]
Es
Se miraron los nietos de closet miran todo
no habia nada solo un poco de fubazinho y
ahí los chicos ya no querían la
su estómago ya no aceptaba y
así que cuando vieron ese
situación decían así la madre entonces
pensábamos que era abuso pero lo es
aquí es realmente necesario, Clei está con
mucha hambre
[Música]
ya
comió
entregado
[Música]
Es
gracias Jesús
viene mucha comida
es diferente que no se ni que comida
que vi mucha comida de verano y que
son tantas cosas, tantas donaciones que ahora yo
que no tenia nada hoy tengo que
ser capaz de ayudar a la gente
tú
está en la casa
de la abuela
Y allá
[Música]